our meetings the African Union and EU
PSC meetings Peace and Security Council
on the African site the political and
security committee on our side are an
extremely useful tool in order to
exchange views yesterday in a more
informal setting we have discussed the
issue of countering terrorism but also
countering radicalization and violent
extremism on the one side and then the
other side also the issue of migration
today we focused on the crisis
situations in Africa namely the
Democratic Republic of Congo the Central
African Republic Somalia Sahel South
Sudan Burundian guinea-bissau then we
had also a conversation on how we could
even further strengthen our cooperation
African Union European Union but also
between our two comedies and the idea of
maybe a joint trip which we have already
undertaken one in in Mali about a year
and a half ago which was extremely
successful so we want to build on that
the retreat did focus on terrorism and
migration two huge concerns for both our
continents and we did come up with
concrete outcomes and a way forward and
how we can work together to deal with
these two situations on the Democratic
Republic of Congo we appraise ourselves
on the situation and agreed that this
country was to be encouraged to hold
elections as quickly as possible on the
Central African Republic we agreed that
we need to remain involved with this
country that is still quite fragile to
ensure that they're able to build
governance and administrative
institutions we also appreciated a need
to support Somalia during this time as
they work towards having elections and
and obviously the issues of state
formation and capacity building within
the Somali National Army which would
then take over from Amazon
on South Sudan we appreciated that South
Sudan had finally accepted the
deployment of the Protection Force we
discussed the possibility of having
joint missions to a crisis situation we
had one in the past O'Malley that was
very successful and we both organs
agreed that this is something that we
would do in the near future